it's looking increasingly likely that
two of North America's League of Legends
goats Bjergsen and doublelift are going
to be playing again on the same team
both of these guys announced their
retirements in the last couple of years
but here we are it's a bit of a crazy
story a lot of people are very happy
about this but I want to ask is it
actually good for the LCS
[Music]
for most of you guys watching it's
probably getting a bit colder outside
these days you need to bundle up you
need some new clothes you can get some
new clothes from us we have a brand new
merch line out this year lots of really
cool sick things a lot of hoodies that
are great for the winter my favorite is
the one that says touch grass it's a
nice reminder just to get outside even
though there won't be as much grass in
the winter you know it's good to keep it
keep it in the brain click the link in
the description below so last weekend
Bria Sieger also known as LEC wulu
reported that hundred thieves had
reached a verbal agreement with double
lift and Bjergsen for them to play for
the team in the LCS next season and this
was basically confirmed by double list
girlfriend Lena on stream this week
obviously now he's playing for 100
thieves and you know I'm unsus and such
thing as the biggest competitor for
Essentials and in the like any balance
space I guess
did I leave everyone knows guys
now if you've been paying any attention
to North American League over the past
few years you'll probably find this a
little bit surprising Bjergsen and
doublelift were teammates during what
many TSM fans feel was the team's Golden
Era back in 2016. that roster looked
pretty much Unstoppable and it was in
large part due to these two doublelift
ended up leaving for Team Liquid where
he dominated for another two years and
he wasn't afraid to hold it over
Bjergsen either what do you think of TSM
split so far uh looking pretty boosted I
I don't know if they're gonna if they're
gonna make it but uh I'm really glad I'm
not in there she is you know I've been
there and I don't want to be there again
so that you guys are just straight up
boosted so what's tomorrow's game gonna
look like wow
uh I mean it would really suck for him
if he loses to us after calling us
boosted so but in summer 2020 doublelift
rejoined TSM once again a lot of people
were surprised I was very surprised but
now the question was would these two be
able to find that spark again in the
regular season the answer was uh kind of
csm's inability to close out games left
them lagging behind Cloud9 and Team
Liquid eventually finishing fourth in
the regular season but when playoffs
came around they were a bit of a
different Beast especially Bjergsen they
had to battle through the lower bracket
but eventually got their seventh LCS
title and earned North America's number
one seed going into Worlds of that year
and what fellow next has been burnt into
the memory of every TSM fan out there I
know that because it's happened to me
TSM crashed and burned in the group
stage that year failing to pick up a
single win and leaving with an 0 and 6
record now world's 2022 that just
happened recently was a historically bad
year for North America but all of the
teams that represented n a at least
managed to pick up a single win I'm just
comparing that to tsm's year A couple of
years ago just to put that in
perspective doublelift and Bjergsen both
announced they were retiring as Pro
players in the months after the
tournament the dream team was over but
while double F became a full-time
streamer Bjergsen stayed on with the
team as their coach for the 2021 season
and despite the team finishing second in
Spring and First In Summer during the
regular season they fell apart during
playoffs and failed to qualify for
worlds for the third time in four years
then a year ago today Bjergsen came out
of retirement as a player to join team
liquid's roster for the 2022 season Once
Again a lot of people were surprised I
was surprised I thought he was going to
retire with TSM in any capacity he was
the face of that franchise in many ways
but it seemed like Bjergsen felt he
still had something to prove on the real
and the TSM wasn't the place to do it
this was around the time that the whole
double lift versus ready drummer was
flaring up if you're interested in that
I've made like five videos on it over
the past year and also a lot of other
key faces were leaving the org as well
but despite flourishes from the team
liquid super team I think it's fair to
say they didn't live up to expectations
this year resulting in them failing to
qualify for worlds and so that brings us
to the present where almost unbelievably
Bjergsen is swapping teams again and
doublelift is joining him on that team
over two years since his last Pro game
he spent a lot of the past year doing
much love co-streams with former pros
meteos and sneaky I almost exclusively
watch LCS games through these guys so it
will be weird to watch it with no double
lift now they're rumored to be joined by
tenacity in the Top Lane busio in
support and hundredth thieves season
Mainstay closer in the jungle now on
paper this feels like a well-balanced
roster busio and tenacity have been real
homegrown success stories for hundreds
of Thieves they've been with with the
org either as a sub player or an academy
player for the last two or three years
respectively just to put this in
perspective when doublelift first went
pro back in 2011 his new support busio
was just seven years old
seven years old
just let that sink in and I'm actually
wondering if this 10-year Gap could be
the largest gap between two teammates in
League of Legends history I think it
might be maybe you guys can let me know
now we could sit here and do a deep dive
on this prospective roster but I think
it's good to take a step back here and
talk about what this means for na as a
whole the initial reaction I've seen is
that this is good for n a Bjergsen and
doublelift are the two most famous the
two most loved and the two most
successful players in LCS history having
them on the same team is obviously huge
for the scene these guys can
single-handedly boost the viewing
figures of any game they happen to be in
and the two of them together even more
so we know their faces we know their
stories we know their relationship with
each other all of this makes people want
to tune into the LCS and see what their
next chapter holds now I did a video
about the General Health of the LCS not
too long ago and I said this but I think
right is recognizing the two key things
that have been missing from the LCS
recently when compared to those golden
day days stories and personalities maybe
I'm seeing it through Rose tinted
glasses here but it feels like in the
past players spoke their minds more
there was a bit more of an edge to
things and genuine rivalries going on
those Golden Days of big personalities
epic storylines and healthy trash
talking often involve Bjergsen and
doublelift and obviously the fact that
they might be back on the same team
together is good if you want to continue
that Trend I'm very much on board with
that I've been a fan of these two guys
as long as I've been a fan of league but
I don't think anyone's going to shun the
opportunity to watch them play together
once again but there is a part of me
that is concerned the fact that this is
exciting news that's going to kick some
life back into the LCS
is kind of sad on some level what does
it say about the state of the LCS that
despite it being about a decade since
these guys stepped onto the scene
there's still arguably the biggest
audience draw now I want to be clear
that I'm not doubting their skill or
their place in any LCS starting roster
here I still think Bjergsen is a top
five mid in the LCS and he's rarely ever
the reason his team loses as for
doublelift well almost every single time
people have doubted him in the past he
just comes back and wins another LCS
trophy for the fun of it so I think this
could be a similar situation it's not
concerning that they could just walk
into a starting roster after all this
time credit to them it is concerning
that this is so exciting for the na
scene as a whole one day Bjergsen and
doublelift will retire I mean like
actually retire for good this time I
know they did two years ago apparently
but one day in the not too distant
future they will be gone they will hang
up their keyboards for good the scene
won't be able to rely on Old Pros like
them making Grand returns to generate
excitement there will need to be another
double left on Bjergsen by then and
don't get me wrong I know it exists in
the scene on some level for example JoJo
I've been such a fan of his over the
past year I think a lot of people who
watch the LCS have been too he's a real
breath of fresh air and he has that
spark that just sort of draws people in
both gameplay and personality wise but
the LCS is gonna have to produce that
kind of player many more times over if
it wants to survive another 10 years I'm
excited that it looks like Bjergsen and
doublelift the two goats of North
America are going to be playing
alongside each other once again that is
indisputably sick let's just hope the
LCS finds stories to compete with them
in 2023
[Music]
foreign